[Music]  Taylor Swift brings her a game to end  games I wanna be  [Music]  and game miss Swift is not playing in  her latest music video she takes us on  the ultimate international trip to three  continents first she likes of Miami with  future then she travels to Tokyo with ed  Sheeran and finally she lives it up in  London we can also tell you Katy Perry  does not appear in the video yes  [Music]  back in December when photos leaked from  the set fans speculated that this dancer  was Katy Perry herself perhaps making a  surprise reconciliation between the two  alas no KP and game is the third video  off Taylor's latest album reputation  while look what you made me do and ready  for it had complex narratives or pretty  stoked to see Taylor simply letting  loose and having fun in end game I don't  understand how you cannot fangirl about  that  [Music]